ariana grande shines bright like the
moon in a new promotional video for
season 21 of the voice
oh whoa look at that amazing star over
there you mean alpha centauri
no i mean ariana grande
yeah okay she's sitting on the moon too
i'm happy
life is good the pov singer is joining
blake shelton
john legend and kelly clarkson as a
coach on the upcoming season of the hit
competition series
and in a new promo for the show ari puts
her vocal skills
on full display hi guys sorry i'm late
hey
so ariana i'm not sure if you're aware
but we kind of have a tradition the new
coach has to sing us a little song
around the campfire
so awkward i i couldn't possibly
um does anyone else want to buy that
track
i think that this is going to be a
really fun one for us
and when it comes to ari joining the
voice team
i think blake put it best this is going
to be an amazing season
on monday the 28 year old singer shared
these behind-the-scenes pics and clips
from the promo shoot on instagram
today we are shooting our very first
promo for
the boys season 21. it's very fun
everyone is at a beautiful campfire
and i'm of course dressed very
appropriately
i was just entering on this really
beautiful crescent moon which i love i
have a moon tattoo
my floating moon entrance felt very
special
she captioned the post in part quote
hello
and screaming cannot wait for everyone
to see our first promo tomorrow for
season 21 of the voice
it's the most ridiculous and fun
i feel in love every day as for her new
co-workers
ari wrote quote i adore these humans so
much
and am already an emotional wreck
worrying about saying goodbye to
everyone the day of the finale
and nothing's even happened or aired yet
kelly
also shared a sneak peek on twitter
today's promo is about how we
regularly just chill around a campfire
and sing
and the whole thing is kind of cute and
it's outdoorsy this is us welcoming
ariana
back in may et spoke with outgoing voice
coach nick jonas about ari joining the
team
and he had nothing but praise for the
newcomer she's brilliant obviously
she'll she'll
nail it i've said this to someone else
you know i think the best thing to do is
just not to trust
i think the only proper way to end this
video is to celebrate ari joining the
voice
by letting her do what she does best
sing
specifically those iconic whistle notes
i mean ariana grande